>>> THE UNITED NATIONSEFUGEE
AGENCY ESTIMATES AROUND 660,000
UKRAINIANS HAVE SO FAR FLED TO
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
THE THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN ARRIVING
AT A POLAND TRAIN STATION
SEEKING SAFETY FROM RUSSIA'S
INVASION, TRYING TO STAY WARM IN
THE FREEZING COLD TEMPERATURES
THAT ARE IN UKRAINE RIGHT NOW.
OUR CNN SENIOR CORRESPONDENT
SARA SIDNER JOINS ME NOW LIVE
FROM THE BORDER OF UKRAINE AND
POLAND.
SARA, YOU'VE BEEN SHOWING THIS
REALLY REMARKABLE SCENES OF
VOLUNTEERS, PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME
OUT, POLISH PEOPLE, PEOPLE FROM
GERMANY, ALL AROUND THE REGION,
TO HELP THESE UKRAINIANS WHO ARE
POURING OVER THE BORDER.
>> Reporter: IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
SHOW OF SUPPORT, OF HUMANITY, IF
YOU WILL, ANDERSON.
I'LL GIVE YOU ANOTHER QUICK LOOK
AT THIS.
THIS IS VOLUNTEERISM AT ITS
ABSOLUTE BEST.
THIS IS NOT A GOVERNMENT-LED
SITUATION.
THIS IS PEOPLE WHO GOT ONLINE,
GATHERED TOGETHER.
SOME OF THEM DO NOT KNOW EACH
OTHER.
SOME OF THEM ARE STRANGERS, BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN HERE DAY IN AND
DAY OUT DOING JUST WHAT YOU'RE
WATCHING NOW, OFFERING FOOD,
OFFERING DRINKS, OFFERING A HOT
CUP OF COFFEE, OFFERING A HOT
SOUP, TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE FEEL WELCOME.
THERE WAS EVEN A SIGN WHEN WE
FIRST GOT TO THE TRAIN STATION,
ONE OF THE VERY FIRST STOPS THAT
YOU END UP AT WHEN YOU LEAVE THE
BORDER OF UKRAINE INTO POLAND,
AND THERE, THERE WERE SIGNS UP
THAT SAID, UKRAINIAN, WE ARE
WAITING FOR YOU HERE IN POLAND.
WELCOME TO POLAND.
SO, IT IS OPEN ARMS FOR MANY
REFUGEES.
I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU ANOTHER
LOOK, BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS EARLIER, AT SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON
HERE.
SO, WHAT YOU ARE SEEING ARE
TENTS SET UP, AND YOU'VE SEEN
THIS, ANDERSON, IN THE MANY
TIMES THAT YOU HAVE REPORTED
FROM ANY KIND OF DISASTER
SITUATION, RIGHT?
YOU'RE SEEING TENTS, AND THESE
TENTS HAVE BEEN SET UP.
THEY HAVE BEEN SET UP SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET WARM, SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN SLEEP AT SOME POINT
IN TIME.
LOOK AT WHAT IS -- I MEAN,
PEOPLE ARE BRINGING WHATEVER
THEY COULD MUSTER.
THESE ARE THE MEAGER BELONGINGS
OF FOLKS WHO HAVE LEFT THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES BEHIND AS WE HAVE
SEEN SO MANY TIMES WHEN WAR
COMES TO A COUNTRY, WHEN
REFUGEES ARE CREATED BECAUSE
SOME GREEDY DESPOT WANTS TO TAKE
SOMETHING OVER.
SO, WE ARE SEEING THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, AND HERE WE ARE
AGAIN, ANDERSON, IN 2022, AND
WAR IS BEING PERPETRATED ON A
PEOPLE WHO DID NOTHING TO
PROVOKE IT.
ALL THEY'RE TRYING TO DO NOW IS
SURVIVE AND EVENTUALLY GO HOME.
BUT THEY JUST DON'T KNOW WHEN
THAT'S GOING TO BE.
>> AND THERE ARE SO MANY -- I
MEAN, THIS IS WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WHO HAVE HAD A LONG JOURNEY JUST
TO GET TO THAT SPOT.
I MEAN, JUST GETTING OUT OF
UKRAINE FOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN
IS EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT.
IT CAN TAKE DAYS AND DAYS AND
DAYS.
TRAIN RIDES, BUS RIDES, WALKING
LONG DISTANCES IN THE FREEZING
COLD, SLEEPING OUTSIDE AT TIMES.
WHEN WE CROSSED OVER FROM THE
BORDER FROM POLAND, I THINK IT
WAS YESTERDAY OR TWO DAYS -- I
GUESS YESTERDAY MORNING, I MEAN,
THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
WAITING.
THERE WAS AN ELDERLY MAN WHO
WE'RE TOLD HAD DIED AT THE
BORDER CHECKPOINT FROM MAKING
THE JOURNEY.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS A HEART
ATTACK OR EXHAUSTION, BUT HE WAS
COVERED WITH A TARP.
IT IS JUST A CHAOTIC SCENE.
I'M WONDERING, WHERE DO THE
PEOPLE GO FROM THERE?
ARE UKRAINIANS ALLOWED TO, THEN,
GO INTO POLAND?
I KNOW THERE WAS A BUS TO TAKE
PEOPLE TO BERLIN FROM GERMAN
VOLUNTEERS.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM FROM HERE?
>> Reporter: I'M GLAD YOU ASKED.
LET ME COME OVER HERE AND SEE IF
I CAN GET YOU A PICTURE.
THE BUSES FOR THE MOST PART HAVE
JUST LEFT, BUT IF YOU LOOK JUST
BEHIND ME, YOU'LL SEE, LIKE, A
TRUCK PULLING UP.
PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY COMING FROM
THEIR HOMES.
PEOPLE IN POLAND ARE SAYING,
HEY, DO YOU NEED A RIDE?
DO YOU NEED A RIDE TO KRAKOW?
DO YOU NEED A RIDE HERE?
DO YOU WANT TO COME TO MY HOME
AND STAY WITH ME?
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS
COUNTRY, SO YES, UKRAINIANS ARE
BEING OFFERED A PLACE TO STAY IN
PEOPLE'S HOMES, AND THE
GOVERNMENT IS SAYING, HEY, YOU
CAN COME IN.
THEY ARE -- THEY AREN'T EVEN, AT
SOME POINTS, CHECKING PAPERS,
AND THEY'RE ALLOWING NOW
CHILDREN ON THEIR OWN TO BE ABLE
TO COME OUT OF UKRAINE AND INTO
POLAND, AND YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT WHAT YOU SAW ON THE
BORDER, AND WE SAW SOMETHING
VERY SIMILAR, WHICH IS
HEARTBREAKING.
WE SAW A 15-YEAR-OLD GIRL WHO
SAYS SHE HAD JUST CROSSED OVER
FROM UKRAINE BY HERSELF TO MEET
HER MOTHER WHO HAD COME FROM, I
THINK, BELGIUM, AND SO SHE HAD
SHOWED UP FROM BELGIUM TO MEET
HER DAUGHTER, AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, I LOOK OVER, AND THE
MOTHER HAS FAINTED.
NO PULSE.
SHE HAD NO -- SHE WASN'T
BREATHING.
THERE ARE MEDICS THERE FROM
ISRAEL WHO HAD SHOWN UP TO
VOLUNTEER FROM AN ORGANIZATION
THAT'S SIMILAR TO DOCTORS
WITHOUT BORDERS CALLED RESCUERS
WITHOUT BORDERS, AND THEY WERE
LITERALLY WORKING ON THIS WOMAN
ON THE FREEZING COLD GROUND AND
TRYING TO REVIVE HER.
AND BY GOD'S GRACE, SHE WAS
REVIVED.
THE MEDICS GOT HER BREATHING
AGAIN.
SHE HAD A VERY LIGHT PULSE, BUT
THE DAUGHTER IS STANDING THERE
AND WONDERING WHAT SHE'S
SUPPOSED TO DO.
YOU CAN SEE THE PANIC AND THE
HEARTACHE, AND SHE'S CRYING AND
TALKING ON THE PHONE, TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO NOW
BECAUSE THEY'RE TAKING HER
MOTHER TO THE HOSPITAL.
AN AMBULANCE CAME ABOUT 30
MINUTES LATER, AND THE
DAUGHTER'S STANDING THERE,
GOING, I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
WHAT DO I DO?
MY MOTHER -- I WANT TO GO HOME.
SO, IT'S A REALLY, REALLY,